After long hours at work, even actors need
to blow off steam.
But not even Hollywood's finest are immune
to a good, weird prank — and they can get
pretty strange.
In honor of April Fool's day, here are some
of the most bizarre on-set pranks.
Chris Pratt's full Andy
During his time on Parks and Recreation, Chris
Pratt was known to improvise almost constantly.
"I was born at 17 months with a full head
of hair, and a full head of teeth."
So, during a scene where his character, Andy,
shows up in the buff, Pratt was supposed to
be wearing flesh-colored undies, which could
be blurred out later.
But since It was April Fool's Day, he thought
it would be better just to ditch the undies
and just go with his birthday suit... without
telling anyone.
"Baby I'm back!"
"Thank you so --- oh!"
In an interview with Graham Norton, Pratt
revealed his motivation for the prank.
"To me, it didn't really seem like she was
reacting to seeing my d---.
And so I was like, 'I know what I'm gonna
do!'"
Apparently, NBC wasn't thrilled, and he got
a letter from the network reprimanding him
for his behavior.
He reacted in typical Chris Pratt fashion:
he framed the letter and hung it in his office.
J-Law gets bugged to death
Like most people, Jennifer Lawrence is terrified
of bugs.
Since Hollywood's sweetheart has pretty much
no filter when it comes to sharing things
about herself, that fact was probably common
knowledge on the set of Hunger Games: Catching
Fire.
So, of course, her costar Jeffrey Wright thought
it would be funny give Lawrence a blue Tiffany's
box...with a surprise.
"What was in that?"
"Well, about as many crickets as I could cram
into the box."
Wright didn't get away without a little bit
of karmic punishment, though.
He went on to say that it was really hard
to stuff a bunch of live crickets in a little
box, so as a result, he ended up with his
very own hotel room plague.
Jennifer Lawrence seems to get involved in
more on-set pranks than your average actor.
While shooting American Hustle, Lawrence was
nervous about filming in a graveyard.
So her co-stars Christian Bale and Bradley
Cooper had the prop team make a personalized
headstone to sneak into the scene that read:
"Jennifer Lawrence, born August 15, 1890,
died April 1, 1913."
Lawrence reportedly screamed and said, "That's
MY name!
Is this just a coincidence, or am I going
to die?"
Her co-stars quickly came clean, and the whole
graveyard scene was cut anyhow.
But making someone think about their own fleeting
mortality is always a pretty great joke, right?
Right?
Fat Damon
During the filming of The Monuments Men, Matt
Damon was especially serious about slimming
down for his role.
So, naturally, whenever Damon flew back to
New York during filming breaks, George Clooney
would take all of Damon's clothes to the wardrobe
department and have them made slightly smaller.
Damon couldn't figure out why his clothes
were always too small, causing him hit the
gym even harder.
It wasn't until much later that Damon figured
it all out — and only after the psychological
damage had been done.
"I found that only a few days ago that it
really disturbed you."
"Yeah, and I didn't, I never said anything
because I thought I was being professional
and trying to lose weight and it wasn't working."
Even after all of that, Damon says that he
would never try to prank the notorious prankster
back, saying that he doesn't want to "poke
the bear."
When you get into a prank war with Clooney,
you might not survive.
Fishing for Leo
After weeks of playing the victim to Leonardo
DiCaprio's roughhousing on the set of Wolf
of Wall Street, Jonah Hill felt like he needed
a little retribution.
So during the first take of the film's sushi
scene, everything went as planned, and Hill
ate everything on his plate.
But later, Hill went off script and let DiCaprio
take the last piece.
"You gonna eat that last piece of yellowtail,
bud?"
"It's all, it's all yours."
Now, imagine doing that 70 times.
Hill was familiar with director Martin Scorsese's
penchant for shooting the same scene over
and over.
And over.
By the end of the night, DiCaprio had eaten
an entire school of yellowtail.
For some, that's a regular night, but for
sushi lightweight DiCaprio, it meant puking
into a trash can.
Of course, after this scene, Hill probably
had more than enough fish for one film.
The Yentl of Doom
Not even Steven Spielberg is immune to the
lure of on-set pranking.
During a scene in Indiana Jones and the Temple
of Doom, Harrison Ford is tied up and whipped
by a rather gigantic man.
During one take, rather than employing one
of the bad guys from the film, Spielberg had
Barbra Streisand show up, fully dressed up
in leather, to do the whipping.
With each lash, Streisand would berate Ford
for his movies
To top things off, Carrie Fisher also shows
up to shield Ford, and give him a kiss.
Well played, Spielberg.
Star struck by Viggo
Peter Jackson's sprawling Lord of the Rings
films are beautiful, well-acted, and kinda
violent.
That could be why Viggo Mortensen decided
to start a new tradition on set.
According to multiple co-stars, Mortensen
head butts people.
Hard.
It's kind of like his way of saying "hello",
except the phenomenon spread, and caused more
than a few temporary blackouts on set, like
when Orlando Bloom was clobbered.
"And I'm thinking, 'I might never see again.'"
"Heehee.
But I think he enjoyed it."
The tradition followed through all three movies
and the red carpet, and Elijah Wood called
it "spontaneous, violent love."
When you start calling concussions "love,"
it's time to find new friends.
"Ohhh!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!